[Musique]
on a tous des vieilles photos qu'on
aimerait bien retoucher sauf que pour
changer des couleurs pour changer un
fond ajouter un filtre à tout le monde
sait faire mais dès qu'il faut ajouter
quelque chose ou changer quelque chose
sur la photo
23 heures passées hier soir l'article 2
est mise au vote le scrutin est ouvert
et le coup pré tombe pour l'exécutif
n'a pas adopté les députés de
l'opposition exultent
les insoumis se lèvent comme le montrent
cette vidéo tournée par l'un d'entre eux
bien que cela soit interdit madame Braun
Pivet me fait penser à ma professeur de
musique en classe de 4e au collège ma
professeur de musique ne possédait pas
le fluide de l'autorité et nous étions
des cartes de mentirulus nous en
profitons en lui faisait la misère comme
on me disait pas l'époque l'Assemblée
nationale est une classe de 4e la France
insoumise à bordéliser la salle et
Madame Brown Pivet comme ma professeur
de musique jadis n'y arrive pas
comment tu vas tu veux savoir bien moi
[Rires]
les micro finissent par être coupés
quand certains députés de gauche
commencent à entonner on est là chant
associé notamment aux gilet jaune Yaël
brande PV les rappels à l'ordre
non non vous vous croyez où
non mais c'est incroyable j'ai de la
compassion pour Madame Braun Pivet parce
que je l'imagine le soir fatigué là
c'est que c'est des par cette classe
qu'elle ne maîtrise pas hélas elle
participe au chahut puisqu'elle ne peut
le contenir je lui souhaite néanmoins du
courage certains députés sont
insupportables bon courage donc encore
trois jours à tenir message au musée
Grévin si les propriétaires de la statue
de cire du monsieur en doudoune qui est
en arrière-plan peuvent venir la
récupérer ça arrangerait tout le monde
pour les moins de 21 ans mais c'est une
amélioration du dispositif carrière
longue pour ceux qui ont commencé à
travailler tôt par rapport à ce que
Madame Touraine a proposé
ils ont posé ce monsieur en doudou la
personne et qui est toujours là
récupérer le s'il vous plaît qu'est-ce
que c'est Tik Tok ah bah voilà c'est un
réseau et vous pouvez être dessus et des
gens pouvaient vous voir ah bon c'est un
peu comme un SamG ou Facebook
et voilà ça a commencé comme ça
[Musique]
en gros on comprend que ceux qui ont
commencé à travailler à 17 ans ou à 21
ans pourront partir au bout de 43 ans
mais pas ceux qui ont commencé à 16 ou
18 ans mais enfin c'est complètement fou
mais enfin
ces gens sont ils ont perdu le sens
commun ils ont perdu le sens quand même
donc à 18 ans tu fais pas 43 ans mais à
17 ans tu le fais les commentaires il y
en a à dire oh il est thug par exemple
ou alors c'est c'est swag ou alors il a
date ça tout ça c'est des termes de
jeunes que je connaissais pas du tout
alors je les prends je les note
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
pendant ce temps leur tourner les débats
n'avancent pas 14000 amendements à
examiné d'ici vendredi soir puis ce sera
le Sénat le Parlement a jusqu'au 26 mars
pour se prononcer
pourquoi la réforme des retraites
pourrait être appliquées par ordonnance
c'est ça qui est beau avec l'Assemblée
quand on pense avoir fait le tour on est
encore surpris
mais parce qu'il y a une odeur bizarre
voilà ce que m'ont dit des députés en
quittant l'hémicycle une question reste
donc en suspens qui
a pété plus d'infos dans notre prochaine
édition Laura John sont en couple depuis
9 ans dès le début de leur relation John
a indiqué à sa compagne qu'il détestait
l'épée vraiment il lui a dit
sur table seulement après novembre
relation un drame a eu lieu Laura a
accidentellement lâché un gaz devant son
conjoint le pire des scénarios s'est
produit j'ai pété
et c'était pas une petite odeur
inoffensive mon mari m'a regardé avec
l'expression la plus dégoûtée que j'ai
jamais vu c'est une vraie histoire sinon
vous êtes un grand voyageur à part ça
vous avez déjà fait d'autres
destinations il y a quelques années oui
le proche le Moyen-Orient la Jordanie
notamment
les dates ou pas oui
John n'a pas du tout qui fait cet
accident il lui a tout de suite lancé
Laura c'est révoltant péter la chose la
moins féminine qu'une femme puisse faire
et sachez qu'aujourd'hui voilà Laura et
John vont se séparer
voilà et apparemment
voilà et apparemment voilà c'est terminé
il veut plus en entendre parler
c'est la Saint-Valentin ou c'est le
match
une catastrophe on est passé à jouer à
quelques centimètres
tout ça bon bref il y a le match retour
heureusement c'est la nullité crasse
intergalactique de Christophe Galtier
qui doit évidemment quitter le club au
plus vite parce qu'il ne sert
strictement à rien du tout tactiquement
c'est le néant absolu depuis que les
catharis sont dans ce club jamais le PSG
n'a joué un match de Coupe d'Europe de
cette façon finalement on s'en sort pas
si mal en ce moment paris joue pas bien
ça c'est clair on a joué un quart
d'heure quand baper est rentré donc on
joue pas bien et finalement on s'incline
que 1 0 face une équipe allemande qui
est pas non plus extraordinaire donc
tous les espoirs sont permis il y a
trois semaines pour rebondir ou mourir
c'est ça le plan le plan évidemment on a
compris que c'était l'entrée de Mbappé
on va te donner le ballon vas-y cours
qu'il y a cours l'impression c'est
Forrest Gump vas-y cours cours vas-y va
chercher les ballons ça c'est la
tactique ça ça c'est un entraîneur mais
c'est une blague